Okay so, welcome to this interview.
We are talking with Chris Chew,
who is one of the Udacity engineers, and he's been working on App Engine.
And we're going to talk a little bit today about how Udacity uses App Engine in
production, and some of the things that are different from writing toy apps.
You know, we've been writing these simple things, and
Udacity actually has thousands of users, and so
it's a much different problem that they are solving.
So we spoke before about how when you,
when you came to Udacity, you were skeptical about App Engine and, and
you expected to try to have to convert people.
And how, how has your experience been so far?
>> And yeah, actually, and it's, it's been interesting.
I think a lot of people,
especially the more engineering experience you have, the more skeptical you
tend to be about something that makes claims as big as App Engine's claims.
And, you know, everything always has trade-offs, and App Engine has trade-offs.
But, you know, I really did come to Udacity thinking that I would be
able to talk everybody out of moving to something different,
where we'd have a little bit more control.
And I think the opposite has actually happened.
I'm, I've been a little converted the other way, and I think,
you know, App Engine's really the perfect spot for
Udacity, and Udacity really does run on App Engine.
We really do have a lot of traffic, and there's even some larger websites that
have way more traffic than we do that run successfully on App Engine.
>> Okay, actually so I had, I had the same thought.
You know, we decided to use App Engine because, you know,
I thought it would be easy to get up, get up and online for students, so
they wouldn't have to do sys admin things.
But, you know, I have always done my own thing as well, and not used App Engine,
so I was highly skeptical, and I've had a similar, similar change of heart.
So what are some of the things that App Engine does that, that make it so
nice to work in, that you would otherwise have to do on your own?
The big one it always boils to,
they provide a lot of infrastructure caching highly replicated data stores.
They force you to address what consistency means in your application,
you know, and does, you know, the same, does a name have to be updated
everywhere immediately or can, can things be a little bit slower to update.
You know, things like that that building a simple app you just, you know,
you don't have to think and then all of sudden you get really big and
then you have to scramble to try and
redefine, you know, how those sorts of things are going to work in your system.
The queuing, is actually really powerful.
It was really smooth, it seems very reliable and you know,
allows you to build, you know, tasks, and really focus on the tasks,
as opposed to the infrastructure to get the tasks delivered.
The login infrastructure by and large works actually really well.
It may, it works really well considering the scale of logging statements you
can put through it.
>> You, you mentioned the queuing which is funny, cause we actually just spent
a lot of time in the previous interview with Neil from Reddit,
talking about all of the infrastructure Reddit has built around the,
the queues and the pre-computing cache and that sort of stuff.
It was actually really tough for us to build.
and, and there's a lot of things that I think were really tough for us to build.
I wonder if you can mention talk a little bit about how the, the version
handling works in App Engine and how that kind of fits in the bigger picture?
>> Versions are actually really interesting in App Engine.
They, they're different than what I expected and it, so
they actually allow you to upload a totally different code base really, but
going against the same data store and the same services.
And you can use that I guess in a couple of different ways effectively.
One thing is that it enables what we call AB testing.
So, kind of like two versions of a site are running at the same time.
And there's actually an AB testing, some administration there that allows you
to kind of blend, you know, percentage of users in, in a somewhat sticky manner.
So that, you know, you can roll out new features to some users and test them,
and, and as they're more successful, migrate all the users to the new features.
Things like that.
The other thing is that they kind of provide you a way to have,
I think of it as like aspects into a system.
You can actually, you know, you could have a version of an app that is for
mainly administrative tasks, or for purely testing, or for monitoring.
Or and then what you know, your, your normal users would see in, in the site and
they're all running simultaneously and you know, against the same you know,
data storing services but it allows you to kind of,
you know, partition your logic and so you could still reuse models and
things between them And it's it's, it's really,
it was a surprising feature that, in there, and it seems to be really handy.
>> Cool.